you grew up watching American TV shows
in India which shows did you like the
most which captured your imagination
I liked Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles I
although in hindsight I always wonder
what that movie pitch would be like like
imagine when they went into the movie
studio no like I had the best idea for
turtles they're ninjas yeah their father
is a rat who also knows kung fu and they
live in the sewers and like to eat pizza
yeah yeah Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
and it's a fence were it's fascinating
but you're right you wonder why that I
had that idea even beings are insane
yeah I mean I think about it everything
that we idolize butan turtles who are
ninja yeah it just drives me insane but
I love it
Oh funny a funny fact Chuck Lorre who
created Big Bang Theory and many other
famous sitcoms wrote the theme song for
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles that's
right he used to be a musician he's
still a very good he wrote the theme
song to teenage teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
turtles and a half shell to the power
yeah
pretty-pretty great lyricist yeah
Gershwin hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos